statcan notamment qui doit prendre ses
responsabilités qui doit arrêter d'être
le réseau social de la drogue c'est le
réseau social de la drogue snapshot
instagram twitter télégramme se fournir
aux drogues est désormais accessible en
quelques secondes depuis son smartphone
offre promotionnelle fidélisation de la
clientèle
livraison à domicile les réseaux sociaux
sont désormais largement utilisés par
les trafiquants de drogue et ce
phénomène a connu un essor depuis mars
2020 avec la crise sanitaire et la mise
en place des mesures de confinement
alors qu'elle est réellement le poids
des réseaux sociaux dans le trafic de
drogue la police arrive-t-elle à traquer
ces nouvelles formes de deals ou les
trafics au parviennent à échapper aux
mains des autorités
[Musique]
24 heures et puis plus rien c'est le
principe de l'application sap chatte un
canal de communication largement
utilisés par les trafiquants qui ont
pris l'habitude d'utiliser le réseau
social pour échanger avec les
consommateurs et promouvoir leurs
marchandises au delà de leur facilité
d'utilisation si les réseaux sociaux
sont toute emprise et c'est qu'il
présente des avantages non négligeables
pour les trafiquants comme pour les
usagers premier avantage le respect des
mesures de restriction si la présence du
trafic de stupéfiants sur les réseaux
sociaux n'est pas nouvelle elle a séduit
les consommateurs durant la crise du
communisme contraints de rester à la
maison
ils se sont tout naturellement tourné
vers les canaux numériques on se fournit
en drogue
une occasion saisie par certains
trafiquants pour diversifier leurs qu'un
autre communiqué les réseaux sociaux là
le trafic de drogue va en france sont
utilisés depuis le début des années 2010
c'est à dire depuis dix ans on a vu une
forte accélération à partir de 2015 avec
des ce qu'on appelait les cocaïne call
center où le consommateur pouvait donc
appelé comme une plate forme et se faire
livrer à domicile de la cocaïne le
confinement et lakovic 19 a fortement
accéléré le processus
au point qu'aujourd'hui la plupart des
dealers possèdent leurs propres réseaux
sociaux alors ça peut être des réseaux
cryptés mais c'est aussi des réseaux
tout à fait facile d'accès comme un
twitter facebook etc sur lesquelles on
va pouvoir donc voir des vidéos des
images des photos des numéros de
téléphone et le consommateur l'usager va
pouvoir se faire ligne verte
d'après une note d'interpol ces
nouvelles techniques commerciales ont
été observés dans d'autres pays autriche
belgique bulgarie croatie finlande pays
bas mais aussi l'espagne avec la mise en
place de restrictions de circulation
liées à l'incendié
second avantage des réseaux sociaux
qu'il s'agisse de la france ou de
l'étranger
cette extension du trafic ne concerne
pas uniquement la livraison ces
plateformes servent de supports de vente
et on y constate un développement inédit
des pratiques commerciales dans ce
marché très concurrentiel communication
et marketing sont au rendez-vous et même
le black friday s'est frayé une place au
sein de ce commerce illégal
la question aujourd'hui qui est
intéressante je crois à poser c'est
comment en fait les trafiquants
s'adaptent pour permettre
inde et aux usagers c'est à dire au
consommateur et mais aussi à de
nouvelles cibles on pourra se procurer
des produits et comment en fait les
dealers vont pouvoir interagir avec
leurs clients et comment en fait ils
vont favoriser par un climat de
confiance sur la durée les réseaux
sociaux apporte aujourd'hui une solution
très efficace en tout cas cet objectif
faut pas oublier quand même
qu'aujourd'hui on parle de marketing les
dealers sont sont assez assez fort enfin
troisième élément qui favorise le trafic
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est que
trafiquants comme consommateurs
privilégient la livraison à domicile
pour l'aspect sécurité elle présente
l'avantagé d'éviter de se rendre dans un
point de lille où peut régner un climat
d'insécurité mais aussi échappé à une
descente de police et ainsi d'être pris
en flagrant des biens que ces canaux de
communications soient surveillées de
près par la police
leur travail est largement complexifier
puisque l'utilisation de messagerie
crypté présente l'avantagé de passer
inaperçu surveiller les réseaux sociaux
classiques tels que facebook avec un
affichage je me dis que vous avez des
groupes fermés
il est très compliqué pour les forces de
l'ordre de rentrer dans au milieu de ces
de ses réseaux oui c'est sûr rien oui
parler du groupe téléphone et par les
numéros de téléphone oui il ya de quoi
il ya de quoi de détecter les ses
dérives et ses ces nouveaux modes de
trafic sur un réseau crypté comme
snapshot avec la disparition des
messages ces messages retrouve signal de
vente
l'anonymisation des réseaux sociaux et
l'instantanéité de certaines plateformes
en fond de redoutables armes pour les
trafics
si les autorités peinent à endiguer ce
deal 2.0 le trafic traditionnels restent
toutefois majoritaire sur nos
territoires
le dernier rapport de l'observatoire
français des drogues et toxicomanies
soulignent que l'utilisation des
nouvelles technologies d'information et
de communication est loin d'être un
monopole de nouveaux protagonistes et
les méthodes classiques domine encore
largement le marché
ce nouveau système de
de livraison à domicile de vitrine sur
les réseaux sociaux
da c'est nouveau ça commence à bien se
développer donc il est très difficile
mais je ne veux pas croire que le points
de deal comme on dit là bas du tour
instance et du supplanté par ce nouveau
système qui à l'avenir ça va pas être le
nouveau mode de vente moins compliqué
mais ensuite il va falloir trouver les
montreurs il über shittu des nehru chic
on n'en est pas encore là et je pense
que le physique et physique dans des
quartiers sensibles
le ministère de l'intérieur qui fait du
trafic de stupéfiants sa priorité appel
largement les plateformes à promeneur
responsabilité dans l'expansion de ce
commerce tout à fait illégal si ces
applications assurent leur bonne foi
dans la lutte contre le trafic de
stupéfiants dans les faits leurs moyens
sont limités puisque la protection des
données entre en jeu qui plus est
l'absence de représentant légal de ces
entreprises en france qui complexifie
les démarches judiciaires
[Musique]